the Texas border battle it's the
governor of Texas fighting a historic
surge of illegal immigrants drug cartels
sex trafficking all the horrible things
coming across our border and now Abbott
must fight even more fiercely against
Democrats get this lawmakers on the left
want President Biden to take over the
Texas National Guard I'm Harris fauler
you are in the fauler focus Governor
Abbott will not budge he says our nation
is being invaded Texas put up razor wire
as you know to keep the criminals who
are breaking America's laws of Entry out
the US Supreme Court recently cited
though with the Biden ad Administration
saying it could actually take down that
razor wire here's Governor
Abbott because the Biden Administration
has really truly abdicated its
responsibility to secure the border and
enforce the laws Texas very simply is
securing the Border Texas has a right as
a state to stop criminals from coming
into our state Joe Biden's option is to
enforce the laws of the United States
and stop this illegal entry what Texas
is doing is what Americans expect to be
done and we have the latest numbers on
the Goda ways those are people who sneak
into our nation without any of the
cameras or detention or detection system
seeing or being able to capture them
border patrol told Fox News there have
now been 96,000 Goda aways just since
October and do the math on that that's
800 criminals per day they're criminals
because they're breaking into the
country the White House in a back and
forth with
Fox it doesn't seem like there's a lot
of fire in his belly John to stop people
from entering it seems that he he wants
he he's okay with the opposite I don't
think he's lacking any sense of urgency
about the need for border security at
all you say there's no lack of urgency
he's been president for 3 years he has
taken some executive actions but there's
a limit to what executive action can do
and we really need support from Congress
do we have a southern border do we have
a what do we have a southern border yes
ma'am of course we do then how come
people can flow across it every single
day we're working very hard to try to
fix that Martha that's why we need
congressional action that's why the
president asked for additional funding
critics say President Biden and his
homeland secretary could in the crisis
without passing any new laws House
Republicans now have scheduled a vote to
impeach Homeland secretary Alejandro
mayorcas next week Peter Ducey live
outside the White House Peter Harris
roughly 800 border crossers got away
yesterday 800 more will get away today
800 more will get away tomorrow there is
no known plan for them from an
Administration that already has a
yearslong backlog to adjudicate the the
Border crossers they do
catch does President Biden want to
locate these folks who have disappeared
into this country to Parts Unknown so
here's what I will say is that um the
president one of the reasons that the
president is having these negotiation
procedures or process with the Senate uh
with both Republicans uh and Democrat as
I've said many times before is because
we want to deal with what's going on at
the border it's going nowhere house
speaker Johnson says I stand with
Governor Abbott the house will do
everything in its power to back him up
the next step holding secretary
secretary my orcus accountable Abbott
appears to be daring the federal
government to continue suing him
remember it's only been a couple days
since the administration beat him in
court giving them the new ability to cut
razor wire in
emergencies it it's it's hard for me to
tell uh what's going on uh what is clear
is that Joe Biden has from the time he
took off is he actually during the time
that he was campaigning he had no intent
to secure the Border he talked about
open border policies during the campaign
and now he's allowed open border
policies with canly most Americans not
even knowing what that
meant immigration is just not a top
priority for this President as he
campaigns for re-election his schedule
proves it this week it's events on
promoting union jobs promoting access to
abortions Harris Peter duy thank you hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye
mechineni on outnumbered every weekday
at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or set your DVR
also don't forget to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights